[Música]
el descontento resuena desde hace varios
meses en el pequeño reino de eso a ti ni
las manifestaciones contra el rey en
swat y terceros son frecuentes en este
país en el que los partidos están
prohibidos desde 1973 los opositores
quieren una democracia fueron a
presionar incluso frente a la embajada
estadounidense
la oposición le pide a la comunidad
internacional que los ayude a iniciar un
diálogo reclama la liberación de los
prisioneros políticos y la enmienda de
la constitución para que su primer
ministro sea elegido y no designado por
el rey la solicitud fue entregada a la
embajadora estadounidense los
manifestantes tienen la impresión de
haber sido escuchados
lo principal es que no dio esperanza las
cosas no se quedarán ahí pronto
contactará al presidente
las manifestaciones que revientan
esporádicamente en todo el país habrían
causado un centenar de muertes según la
oposición unas 30 según el gobierno
algunos como simbolizó vinieron desde
muy lejos para expresar sus
frustraciones
lo más fashion su pueblo natal está en
la frontera con mozambique y aquí
fallecieron dos personas en las
manifestaciones contra la monarquía
siboniso visita con frecuencia a su
vecina cuyo hijo de 17 años fue herido
gravemente en las manifestaciones del
pasado mes de julio
los shots
[Música]
la policía le disparó cuando era
evidente que era tan solo un peatón
como consecuencia ya no puede caminar ni
sentarse porque su médula espinal quedó
afectada
el joven asegura que no fue un accidente
la policía le disparó con balas reales
ahí es muy triste
desde 'the times'
y
su madre explica que no fue bienvenida
en el hospital porque su hijo paralizado
habría podido llamar la atención de los
medios contra el rey
final y regla stats finalmente tomaron
conciencia que jurar lealtad al rey no
les trae ninguna ayuda
miren un pueblo como este no hay agua
alimentarse es costoso lo mismo ocurre
con las escuelas el régimen actual no
les ayuda por el contrario el sistema
los exprimen es como si aspirará su
sangre de sistema fucking de plata
rafter eso a ti ni sigue siendo un país
muy rural la mayoría de la población
gana menos de dos dólares al día
en swat y tercero reina desde hace 38
años sobre más de un millón de súbditos
este monarca educado en inglaterra casi
no aparece en público
aquí recibe las credenciales de la nueva
embajadora de la unión europea el rey no
contesto a nuestras solicitudes de
entrevista pero su asesor nos explica
que el sistema de gobierno es revisado
cada cinco años
cuando nuestro primer ministro fue
nombrado hubo debates el cual lo dijo
que el rey debería seguir nombrando el
premio ministro y ahora de la nada ya no
quieren eso
hubo comercios incendiados y saqueados
casas clínicas escuelas también
es por ello que el ejército tuvo que
intervenir y usted sabe que los soldados
no usan balas de goma cuando militar le
dice que se larga pero usted no se mueve
y sigue incendiando usted sabe lo que
ocurrirá y eso pasó
tapen la monarquía no tiene la intención
de ceder prueba de ello es el proceso
que tiene lugar en el tribunal de
justicia los detenidos llegan muy
custodiados se trata de dos diputados
encarcelados desde el mes de julio para
defenderse eligieron a un abogado de
renombre militantes de los derechos
humanos ya que su único crimen es
político estos dos miembros de la
asamblea nacional habían apoyado las
manifestaciones populares ahora son
acusados de terrorismo
los dos diputados nunca obtuvieron la
libertad condicional su abogado espera
un largo proceso afuera del tribunal les
explica a las esposas de los detenidos
que nada en el expediente prueba que los
diputados son terroristas el abogado más
seco también había sido encarcelado en
el 2014 por el rey en swat y tercero en
ese entonces le había escrito a barack
obama para ser liberado reconoce estar
preocupado winston
la sabiduría siempre ha querido que la
gente se siente alrededor de una mesa
negocio y encuentre compromisos para
dirimir sus diferencias más que utilizar
el poder y la fuerza para reprimir las
aspiraciones del pueblo
sabemos que cuando empieza la lucha
violenta se vuelve muy difícil controlar
la magnitud de sus efectos destructores
con el paso de los meses los alumnos de
secundaria se suman a los manifestantes
cerca de un centenar de escuelas ya
cerraron sus puertas los jóvenes que no
se reconocen en la monarquía son los
primeros en apoyar el cambio
lo q leen y piensa sin cesar en los
minutos en los que su vida cambió sin
duda no volverá a caminar nunca más pero
encerrado en su habitación nos dice
querer acompañar de lejos esta
revolución que no dice su nombre